Want to know the secrets to living a long life?
Ask someone who has lived one.
A 105-year-old woman from Texas, Pearl Cantrell, has her own tip which she eagerly passes on.
She believes bacon is key to living long and staying healthy.
Recently, a news outlet released a report on Cantrell's love of bacon.
Oscar Mayer got wind of it and sent out the Wienermobile to pay a visit to Cantrell.
She rode in the vehicle and drove through the streets of her town, waving to residents.
After the drive, she was given loads of bacon.
Cantrell stated, "I could eat bacon for every meal."
"And I do."
"I want other people to eat bacon."
"I tell them, too."
Another lady, 101-year-old Nancy Lamperti, has her own secret.
Each day with her lunch, she has two glasses of wine.
At four in the afternoon, she indulges in a glass of Southern Comfort.
Two hours later, she drinks a can of Budweiser.
Amazingly, Nancy sticks to her drinking schedule every day.